الآن إلى شبه الجزيرة الكورية حيث
تواجه كوريا الجنوبية والولايات المتحدة
أكبر تدريبات عسكرية مشتركة بينهما
منذ سنوات ، تصف كوريا الشمالية
التدريبات بأنها تدريبات على الغزو
كانت CNN واحدة من
وسيلتين إعلاميتين فقط تم منحهما حق الوصول إلى التدريب الذي قدمته بولا
هانكوكس.  لم تُشاهد التدريبات على إطلاق النار
منذ بعض الوقت هنا في
شبه الجزيرة الكورية ،
وهو سيناريو هجومها المشترك الكوري الجنوبي
المضاد لغزو من قبل
عدو مجهول على بعد حوالي 30 كيلومترًا و 18
ميلًا جنوب المنطقة منزوعة السلاح
وكوريا الشمالية ، ليس من الصعب تخيل
من  قد يكون هذا العدو هو
التهديد الأكبر كلما
كان التحالف أكبر وكلما زاد
التدريب
والغرض من التدريب ، وأعتقد أن هذا
التهديد هو أننا جميعًا هنا لسبب
واضح وجاهز للقيام
بهجوم مضاد.  العرض
يرتفع وهذا هو مقبض الأمان
الآن كلا الجيشين في مأزق
للإشارة إلى أن هذه هي دفاعية
بطبيعتها
ولكنها بسيطة  ply ليس بالطريقة التي
تراهم بها كوريا الشمالية ،
فهم يعتقدون أن هذه
بروفة لغزو كان لدينا
شقيقة كيم يو جونغ كيم جونغ أون تطلق
عليها تدريبات مناهضة للحرب الشمالية الآن
لم نر هذا منذ بعض الوقت  جزئيًا
بسبب السرية 19. كانت هناك العديد من
التدريبات المحاكاة خلال تلك الفترة ولكن
لم تكن هذه التدريبات الكبيرة بالذخيرة الحية
وأيضًا في عام 2018 ، أوقف الرئيس الأمريكي
دونالد ترامب هذا النوع من التدريبات
قائلاً إنه يريد منح الدبلوماسية
فرصة يطلق عليها الحرب.  الألعاب
التي تقول إنهم ببساطة لم يكن لديهم مكان
أثناء حديثه إلى
زعيم كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ أون بقيادة جديدة
في كل من الولايات المتحدة
وكوريا الجنوبية ، جاء قرار بتوسيع هذه
التدريبات في مواجهة
عمليات إطلاق الصواريخ و
تجربة نووية سابعة مرهوبة الجانب من كوريا الشمالية كوريا الشمالية
توضح أنه ليس في حالة
مزاجية للتحدث إلى الولايات المتحدة أو
كوريا الجنوبية ، لذا ستستمر هذه التدريبات على كلا
الجانبين قائلين إنه من المهم جدًا أن
يكون لديهما المزيد من الفرص  يقاتلوا
معًا ويتدربوا معًا حتى يكون لديهم
الاستعداد لأي شيء قد يأتي
بولا هانكوكس CNN كوريا الجنوبية